but a lot of you are going to say i i
don't really get how you sort of
visually developed your intuition for
this
is there another path and the answer is
uh there is another path
um i don't like it very much as i kind
of alluded to at the start but i will
show you
roughly sort of the brush strokes of it
and then by the end of it i hope you'll
see
why um i don't think it's a preferable
method okay so i guess you could call
this
you could call this the the visual or
the geometric method for doing this
um what's the kind of like algebraic
tool that we can use that will help us
here well
you can see here that what we're trying
to do is search for a maximum value
of something now if you were not in
extension 2 if you were in advanced or
extension 1 in an
exam and you saw that phrase maximum
value
um i suspect your brain would go
immediately to calculus you would say
oh i need to um i need to find an
expression that can be
differentiated and then i can um i can
work with this thing right
so how would you go about trying to
arrive at a derivative for this
so that you could then actually work out
um where like
stationary points and turning points are
well let's have a think about this
together what i'm going to do is i'm
going to make a little heading here
i'm going to say uh method two
i'm going to call this calculus right so
let's just go
um and and name it that now there's a
couple of different ways to go about
this
whoops it is here here but what i'm
going to do is i'm going to say in order
to get this in calculus terms i've got
to
be able to number one deal with these
absolute values right you see how you've
got these
these moduli in there right and the
absolute value is kind of in
you know real number terms it's
shorthand for two different things it's
like there's a positive case
there's a negative case um that makes
differentiating a bit of a pain right
because you're like i don't really want
to handle
um two cases um if i was just
differentiating this there'd be a
positive version a negative version and
in fact there's not just two cases
there's actually
four because you've got the positive
negative for this and then you've got
the positive negative for this and
they change over different spots that
sounds awful so what i want to do
is try and reframe this so it doesn't
have the modulus
notation in it and then i'm going to try
and apply some calculus to it so here's
the way i'm going to go about it
remember
that the absolute value of the modulus
of some kind of
complex number that's going to be equal
to the square root of
the two shortest sides of the right
angle triangle that your complex number
sits in
so that's fine i can handle that but the
only challenge is i
i don't have this in terms of x's and
y's i have this in terms of
thetas this question was given to me
with
theta being the variable or the
parameter if you like right
so i want to keep this not in in terms
of x's and y's
but in terms of thetas how do i do that
well i'm going to have to express this
not in rectangular form but in polar
form
so i want to i'll push this off to the
side we'll refer back to it later
i'm going to say this function of theta
right that's what this is it's the
modulus of e to the i theta minus 2
plus modulus of e to the i theta plus
2. what i can do is i can write it in
polar form because that will keep things
in terms of thetas
but it will also enable me to use this
fact because it gets rid of this modulus
that's what i was trying to avoid
because that's a pain
to differentiate so let's go ahead and
just sort of
write that out instead of writing e to
the theta in polar form
that number is just going to be cos
theta plus i sine theta
minus 2. and then you get the same thing
over here it's cos theta
plus i sine theta and it's going to be
plus 2.
and you're going to see because these
left and right hand modulized so similar
we're going to get a lot of
repetition as we go through this working
okay now in order to use
this formula over here i need to cleanly
separate the real part
from the imaginary part and what i
notice is you can see
in each one you've got the real
component there
and then you've got the imaginary
component there and you've got the same
thing
for both moduli so i'm going to go ahead
and write it like so
i've got this cos theta minus
2 that's the real part
and then i've got i sine theta that's
the
imaginary part so i'm going to put an
absolute value sign there to get the
modulus
what am i adding the same thing
everything is the same except
you can see instead of having a minus 2
in red i've got a
plus two okay so now i am actually ready
to take these uh things which have
moduli sort of notation in them
and convert it into something like this
that's also amazing this is one of the
reasons why this calculus approach is
not
great to say the least but at least it
will get rid of the moduli
the absolute value notation so i've got
a single expression that i can then
differentiate
so what am i going to get well i'm going
to have the square root of
well x squared plus y squared in this
case my x
is going to be cos theta minus 2 and
that thing gets
squared and then i have my y squared
which in this case
is it's going to be sine theta
squared because remember that y there is
just the imaginary component it doesn't
have the
i attached to it so in this case it's
going to give me sine
squared theta then i'm going to pop that
radical sign oops that was very messy
let's just do it this way and be lazy
that'll do okay so i've got my radical
sign going over the top
and as we noted before um what you get
from the other modulus
is almost identical it's just that
instead of cos theta
minus 2 i've got cos theta
plus 2 that's being squared okay good
let's keep going i again have this
square root over the top
and as i start to expand stuff out
you'll see some of this begins to
simplify so i've got
cos squared theta minus
4 cos theta plus 4
and then i'm going to add my sine
squared theta there
so you can see the pythagorean identity
is going to appear in here so that'll be
handy
and then let's pop the square root over
the top
there we go and then what i'm adding is
everything will be the same
except because what i was doing was i
was expanding on the right hand side cos
theta plus 2
the only term that changes is going to
be this 4 cos theta it's going to be a
plus instead of a minus okay this is
looking
promising you can see i've got this cos
squared plus sine squared it happens
twice
so therefore what you're getting is
let's write it in purple that's the one
it's going to be minus 4 cos theta
that's there
and then because i notice there's also
this not only does the 1 become a
constant term underneath the square root
i've also got this plus 4. so i'm going
to write that
i will write that in purple as well
because i'm going to collect like terms
in a second so we'll pop that square
root over the top
that's looking good plus uh everything
is again
the same except that i've flipped around
the sign
on this four cos theta so i get a plus
there
and so now i'm almost there i've got the
square root of
1 plus 4 in each case is 5 minus 4 cos
theta
square root over the top
and then plus everything is the same
but it's a plus four cos theta
okay now i am almost ready to go
in terms of getting from this to a
derivative because i'm trying to
maximize remember that
but in order to do that i think it might
be easier if i write this in index
notation
so i'm going to say f of theta equals
here we go don't have to write these
long
awkward square root signs anymore 5
minus 4 cos theta to the power of half
and also 5 plus 4 cos theta
power of half fantastic all right
hold on to your hats this doesn't look
pleasant at all but
i must differentiate if i'm going to try
and use this calculus approach right so
f dash theta what are we getting well
this is the chain rule isn't it um it's
going to require me to differentiate the
outside
then differentiate the inside so let's
do that one at a time
differentiating the outside i've got
something to the power of a half
so i think about the uh this is the
power rule so i
multiply by the power i write the same
thing
in the inside of the bracket and then i
reduce the power by one
that is the derivative of the outside
and then i need to
multiply by the derivative of the inside
so in that
in this case that's going to be what is
the inside function here it's 5 minus
4 cos theta so cos theta differentiates
into
negative sine theta that negative is
going to cancel with that negative 4
that's already there
so i'm thinking i get 4 sine theta
out the other end so there is the
outside there's the inside that's going
to tidy up in a second
we're going to rinse and repeat for the
other term so everything's going to look
very similar but some things are going
to get flipped around
right so because we've got something
that's still raised to the power of a
half you can see that's still
half out the front and then negative
half is the power but because i've got a
5
plus 4 cos theta that's on the inside
when i do my inside derivative i don't
get positive 4 sine theta
i get negative 4 sine theta okay
this is looking better we've got a lot
of things to deal with here so
first i notice there's this half times
this 4
so half of 4 last i checked was 2.
you've also got that sine theta term
that belongs on the numerator of the
fraction that's about to appear so i'll
write that at the top
and then you have this term in
here remember when you've got a negative
power that's the same as division so
what you've got there
is you're dividing by 5 minus 4 cos
theta to the power of a half
but of course that is just this term up
here that's what i have
on the denominator so i'll pop that in
blue so you recognize
where it came from okay so there's the
first term
and then are you getting are you getting
sick of this yet you're going to have
everything the same
on the right hand side term but instead
of having
a plus 2 sine theta you're going to have
a minus 2 sine theta
and then instead of this 5 minus 4 cos
theta you're going to have 5 plus
4 cos theta so let's go ahead and write
that minus
sign which has come from this minus 4
and then everything else will look very
familiar
except you're going to get that down the
bottom
okay that looks disastrous right
but that is sure enough the derivative